يعني رغم
انخفاض الكبير الذي شهدته المدينه خلال
ايام الماضيه بعد كثافه سبقت ذلك الانخفاض
بالقصف العنيفه الاوكراني على مدينه
دانيسكو ايضا القصف الروسي القصف المتبادل
الا ان
اصابهم نوع من الارتياح والخروج الى
الاعمال والى الشوارع حتى عوده يوم امس
الذي شهد
قصفا عنيفا اوكرانيا استهدف الاحياء
المدنيه يعني اربعه قتلى
واصابات ايضا ربما نرى الصوره تكون ابلغ
من
حديث ان الشوارع خاويه ليست هناك اي حركه
للسير بالمركبات بالفعل الناس عادوا
للتحصن والاختباء في بيوتهم
تخوفا من القصف اضافه الى ذلك ليله امس
شهد قصفا عنيفا روسيا ضد مواقع القوات
الاوكرانيه حسب ما اعلنت الوكالات هنا بان
القصف الذي شهدته الليله الماضيه الطويل
والعنيف حتى الصباح كان من اجل ابعاد
القوات الاوكرانيه التي تستهدف المدينه
اذا سمح لنا الوقت ربما نعرج على اخبار
هامه جدا من ضخ متصلنا وهي اخبار ليست
رسميه لكنها من مصادر موثوقه نايف هناك
حديث عن انسحاب للقوات الاوكرانيه انسحاب
تدريجي من الناحيه الشماليه نحو مدينه
اصلافيان ان القوات الاوكرانيه تمكنت من
ايصال اليات عسكريه
وارتال عسكريه من الجنود ايضا وصلوا بطريق
العوده الى اصلافيانس كما ان القوات
الروسيه تكمل طوقها يعني الكامل على شكل
دائره على مدينه باخمر